e
[Música]
[Aplausos]
el de los usuarios cambiar nada
esto
y niños
los generales
la emocionada larga de las enseñas
y bueno
un hombre muy generoso
sí
por la mañana
y
y hay más
como lector completo pueda contemplar
con eeuu de que somos unos medios
[Música]
y al conocerlos
en el mundo
a entender
[Música]
e
d
bien
[Música]
y cuando somos
nos dicen
y a nosotros mismos
y entonces
[Música]
nosotros
de manera crítica
en sesiones de dos horas
y
[Música]
y a
el tiempo es esencial que cuando el
último se quedando
[Música]
y entonces
de 10 años
los niños
[Música]
y se ha traducido de verdad los cerebros
el amor la violencia y entonces
y eso
su cintura
y por eso vienen habitación
[Música]
los niños
por qué
[Música]
[Aplausos]
vamos
y la que tiene y entonces
y
milan
qué es
y entonces
[Música]
y ellos las estructuras y entonces
y entonces
los niños
[Música]
ah
en el número de personas
[Música]
ah
para terminar
en el libro
i
[Música]
qué
y es que encontramos nucleados
[Música]
y ello lleva a quiénes no
dónde
y
[Aplausos]
voy a diferentes conversaciones
[Música]
y
y sus propios
[Música]
[Aplausos]
terminarás
y en lo que son aves por la vida de los
tresmiles íntegras
pero también nos dice que para describir
a muchísimas junta de sucres
[Música]
[Aplausos]
y
y también de transformar
dice la experiencia de ellos
[Música]
y también
[Aplausos]
[Música]
de la grasa
y
y la escuela
[Música]
y
importantes
para los niños
[Aplausos]
[Música]
cómo
además ellos
[Música]
y quién es
internet nueva realidad
y ahora